i'm here on Church Street in New Haven
where you can find everything you've
ever wanted
there's a rite aid there's a dunkin
donuts there's even an obamacare store
that's right obamacare and it's run by
access health connecticut and it's one
of the reasons why this date has had
more luck than almost any other one in
the country and signing up people for
health care connecticut is one of just
14 states in the country to set up their
own health care exchange but they're the
only one to set up shop in the final
days of enrollment the store is packed
full of people who say they are relieved
to have their questions answered
face-to-face Kevin Counihan is CEO of
access health Connecticut you're
basically on track to have double the
amount of enrollment it's ringing these
350 people are actually pressing the
enroll button I'm actually applying for
coverage right now our average is 211
and this is just google analytics that's
exactly right that's exactly right as
for the stores he credits Apple we're
trying to make this like a retail
experience okay to be frank with you
we're really trying to model a lot of
what we do after apple and we're trying
to create a customer experience and
product innovation around an annual
cycle of new product introduction we
really see ourselves as a private
startup we've had about sixteen thousand
eight hundred people visit the store and
over half of them have purchased our
close-ratio right now is seventy percent
enrollment has been such a success
counihan is now marketing their services
to other states pitching it as an
exchange in a box it's really the
administrative functions of an exchange
that we're looking at allowing states to
outsource I would outsource as much as
possible to somebody else if you can
help it because quite frankly building
the technologies a lot of work and it's
not always that much fun already they've
spoken to five states who are interested
wary of the glitches on the federal site
and impressed how access health has done
so much better than healthcare.gov
Olivia Sterns Bloomberg News